THURSDAY MARCH TENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE ADVISE AN AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
FOR SCENE IS BEING MADE. IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTEND THIS HEARING ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR MASKS AT ALL
TIMES. ATTENDEES MUST ALSO
REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OTHERWISE MPC
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT INDIVIDUALS TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
AND I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
AGAIN HAVE MY COLLEAGUE MY
CLASSMATE FROM TWENTY TWELVE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN MARIE WALDRON
JOINING US HERE ON THE DICE AND
RULES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MARIE
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK- SHE'S
BEEN HERE THIRTY SECONDS AND
SHE'S CLOSE TO ONE OF THE SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE- RULES COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE OUR FORMER SERVICE SO-
EVERYONE A CORD- SOON ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WALDRON TO RESPECT OUR
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HERE WALDRON. YEAH HERE
LARA YOUR MOM GIPSON HERE LEE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RUBIO THE
VALLAPUDUA REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE
A QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUR MOST ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA OVER MAYES RUBIO
SECONDED BY MISS WALDRON A
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE BENNETT.
BENNETT HI FLORA FLORA HI FONG
FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON HI LEE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS FIVE RUBIO RUBIO
IV WHO BY THE APPROVAL HIGH
MOTION PASSES TO MOTIONS PASSED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER. THE
RESTRICTED. FOLKS ARE FREE TO
LEAVE AND I WILL GAVEL DOWN IN A
MOMENT. OKAY THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH VERY GOOD FOR.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.